hi I'm Maggie and I wanted to know what
the future of the universe is and what
is our place in it according to physics
and engineering Thank You Maggie the
future of the universe that's literally
a big question first of all the universe
is accelerating and when I was your age
everybody thought the universe was
slowing down everybody thought the
universe was going slower and slower but
turns out is going faster and faster and
nobody knows why so when it comes to
predicting the future of the universe
there's just got to be a an enormous
amount of information that we don't know
anything about and that will help us
figure out what the future might be but
I gotta tell you I think the universe
will keep going whether or not we're
here I mean that's just what it seems
like I've watched a lot of people come
and go and just seems like the world
keeps spinning and the universe keeps
circulating ever so slowly actually the
enormous speeds perceptibly it looks
very slow to us with that said it's a
cool thing to think about and it's also
reasonable Maggie that you will in
trying to find out what happens in the
future of the universe you'll discover
something amazing something astonishing
and it's very reasonable to me that
you'll find some source of energy that
we haven't thought about 94% depends of
you talked to 96 percent of the universe
is dark matter and dark energy and
nobody really knows what that is and
it's very reasonable if somebody could
figure out what that is way out in deep
space that same stuff is it here
somewhere and if you can figure out what
that is you could tear I say it change
the world and what I am glad you're
pondering this but also think about your
future it's coming up a lot quicker than
like the next the next time the Sun
becomes a red giant for example but
that's billions of years away